in India as heavy rains cause dangerous
mudslides
MPS debate imposing a windfall tax on
profits from oil and gas production
and New Mexico battles its biggest ever
Wildfire as experts say the risk to some
populated areas of America could double
[Music]
and welcome to the UK's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hit hardest by those
changes and report on the race for
Solutions
now South Asia's battled with the
effects of climate change is reaching
crisis levels after weeks of intense
heat waves at least 11 people have now
died in flooding and mudslides triggered
by heavy rains in the northeast of India
and experts say that climate change is
making these events much more common
while the northeastern states of
arunachal Pradesh and Assam are the
latest areas to be badly affected by the
extreme weather with heavy rain causing
flooding and mudslides it follows weeks
of record-breaking high temperatures
which are persisting on Sunday
temperatures hit 49 degrees in the
capital Delhi that's the highest ever
recorded for May and then over the
weekend temperatures soared over 45
degrees in several areas including
Rajasthan Punjab and uttar Pradesh well
scientists say that landslides are
becoming more frequent in the north of
India as global warming contributes to
The Melting of glaciers in a Sam at
least 200 000 people were cut off as
roads and bridges became blocked all
washed away and the Army was called in
to help with the rescue effort there and
the extreme temperatures are affecting
supplies of wheat a much sought after
the commodity at the moment amid Global
shortages of the crop India is limiting
exports of the Grain in an attempt to
keep domestic prices from rising
well our climate reporter Victoria
Seabrook is here so Victoria the extreme
weather having a real impact on Food
Supplies in India and that's part of a
wider issue of food security isn't it
yes exactly so Russia and Ukraine
together together to take wheat for an
example are they produce a quarter of
the world's wheat exports now that's
obviously been terribly disrupted with
the war in Ukraine India produces even
more wheat than Russia and there had
been some hopes that India could perhaps
step in and plug some of that shortfall
but now that's all changed with this
extreme weather they are severely
limiting their their exports and this is
all hitting quite hard because food
prices they were already squeezed even
before the war in Ukraine so energy
costs were going up and of course that
affects the cost of transporting food
that needs to be shipped all over and
fertilizer costs were going up to
fertilizer is made from gas so this
isn't this is an example of how all of
these crises kind of intersect so we've
got climate conflict food and energy
having said that the better news in all
of this I suppose is that some of the
solutions also intersect and overlap so
for example cutting down use of
fertilizer helps to cut emissions it
also Cuts costs and it can be very good
for soils cutting food waste also cut
submissions and helps with costs
Victoria thanks very much indeed
now it's estimated that 28 million more
people than in 2021 are now at high risk
from extreme heat because they lack
access to cooling a report by
sustainable energy for all finds that
people's ability to survive these
increasingly frequent extreme weather
events is under threat well let's get
more on this joining us now is Brian
Dean who's head of Energy Efficiency and
cooling at sustainable energy for all so
welcome to you thanks for joining us so
how great are the risks then of extreme
heat and who's the most vulnerable
yeah these risks are actually continuing
to grow as you showed with uh the
extreme heat in India right now uh these
are
um situations that are affecting mostly
uh those that don't have access to
electricity uh those are in extreme
poverty and we find that there's 1.2
billion people around the world that are
in this situation of being really at
high risk uh without lack of access to
cooling that's the inability to pay for
cooling the inability to have community
services that provide cooling during
heat waves this is affecting rural poor
including those rural Farmers that are
delivering these products to us this
food around the world but it's also uh
from a health perspective uh when when
you don't have a healthcare facility
that has access to electricity in these
rural regions uh they're also at
significant risk both from the health
impact of receiving medical care but
also of course the vaccines which which
we know are so important after this
endemic so those are the major
apologies for interrupting I was just
going to ask what can be done about it
then is this all down to getting cooling
systems in place it's all down to air
conditioning and Refrigeration
no it's a much more complex situation
obviously having access the ability to
afford an air conditioner and uh
Refrigeration that's great for the
middle income the upper income
populations but when you're talking
about those that are in extreme poverty
and those that don't have access to
electricity there are additional
solutions that are needed a heat action
plan for the city those 800 million
people in urban that are lacking access
to cooling those cities need to have the
services in place the warnings in place
for extreme heat waves and the community
cooling facilities uh and for you know
we've found that if people get access to
electricity and those that are just
pulled out of extreme poverty those two
fundamental issues will pull 440 million
people out of this high-risk category uh
by 2030. and we're certainly looking to
push further than that to actually have
those efficient Solutions as well
um which would pull many more people uh
out of this high-risk category and even
medium risk categories
Brian Dean thanks very much indeed
thank you for having me
MPS have voted down a labor Amendment to
the Queen's speech in favor of a
windfall tax on oil and gas producers
but the chancellor at Rishi sunag did
say that no option is off the table if
energy companies don't reinvest their
profits soon well our chief political
correspondent John Craig joins us now
from Westminster John
no option is off the table says Rishi
sunak in what is a pretty thinly Veiled
Threat to the oil companies that he is
prepared uh to bring in a windfall tax
as demanded by labor and a small handful
of conservative MPS if they don't invest
in cheaper energy and energy security
Now during uh day five of The Commons
debate on the Queen's speech Mr sunac
talked about energy companies who've
made extraordinary profits at a time of
acutely elevated prices and they have to
he says invest those profits back into
British jobs growth and energy security
but in his threat to them he said if
that doesn't happen and soon and at
significant scale no option is off the
table well as well as a tax on the oil
and gas companies by opposition MPS
there was some pretty strong language
used by some Tory back benches Robert
Halford the ex-minister who's a big fuel
price campaigner said that the oil
bosses were new the new oligarchs he
said they were earning multi-million
pound salaries multi-million pound
bonuses and he urged the chancellor to
consider a windfall tax on the oil
companies to cut taxes for the lower
paid or cut energy bills also backing
that call was Mel stride the MP who
chairs the treasury Select Committee
now for some of the day's other climate
news and there's a warning today that
fossil fuel production sites need to be
shut down sooner to limit global warming
to a rise of 1.5 degrees a goal agreed
by hundreds of countries around the
world the research published in the
journal environment research letters
analyzed 25 000 oil and gas fields and
found that 40 percent of fossil fuels
already developed mustn't be extracted
for there to be a 50 50 chance of
limiting the increase in the World's
temperature
Iraq and Iran have been hit by severe
sandstorms with Schools and Government
offices across both countries being
forced to close both countries have been
hammered by a series of sandstorms since
April grounding flights and leaving
thousands with breathing difficulties
experts blame desertification low water
levels and climate change for the
frequency and intensity of the recent
storms
Scotland's largest Ultra rapid charging
station for electric vehicles is open
today in South lanarkshire the station's
eight charges Each of which is supplied
by 100 renewable energy are capable of
adding up to 300 miles of range to fully
electric cars in 20 minutes the electric
car Hub operated by fastned was
partially funded by the Scottish
government as part of its strategy to
phase out the country's need for new
petrol and diesel cars by 2030.
climate change is set to cause a steep
increase in the exposure of properties
to Wildfire risks in America over the
next 30 Years according to a new report
it comes as New Mexico battles the
largest ever blaze in its history
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
these are our Coastal winds that we
experience generally every day the big
difference is and we're seeing it again
you know with the climate change the
fuels beds in this County throughout
Southern California throughout the West
are so dry that you know fire like this
is going to be more commonplace
[Music]
coming up next on The Daily climate show
I'll be joined by the chief executive of
the climate group Helen Clarkson and
professor of global climate change
science Simon Lewis and we're going to
be discussing that report that says new
and some existing oil projects need to
stop for temperature rises to be limited
to 1.5 degrees and what do we do about
extreme temperatures
right
foreign
[Music]
and it's moving this way and over there
is Dover we track the changes happening
to our world right now I think it's a
procession of the Taliban there they are
right here which you as prime minister
be able to look them in the face let's
have a look at both of those two things
I just want to say thank you for having
the courage to speak to us we do
genuinely believe in what we do to show
the truth
I thought there was an astonishing story
there
is a lot of truth that's been fired all
around us
[Music]
and now they're going to be arrested we
aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
foreign
[Music]
undated the only way out is to get
people by boat
what is here that over 200 people might
have died because of these landslides
[Music]
that's it
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of Northeast Delhi where there's been
clashes
I'm Neville Lazarus and I'm Skye's
reporter based in Delhi
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the Daily
climate show on Sky News now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with chief
executive of the climate group Helen
Clarkson and Simon Lewis a professor of
global climate change science so a very
good evening to both of you nice to see
you both
so first of all a study today suggests
that nearly half of existing fossil fuel
facilities will need to close down early
if global warming is to be limited to
1.5 degrees now that's a marked Step Up
in language that we heard last year from
the International Energy agency who said
there should be no new investment in
coal oil or gas if the targets were to
be breached so Helen they were actually
raised eyebrows from some when the iea
put out its report last year and this
one goes further and the reason they say
they go further is because they're
saying that we can't rely on technology
to to suck CO2 out of the atmosphere are
they right do you think to rule that out
couldn't that technology make a big
difference
yeah I think they are right and I think
it's this is a real wake-up call to the
oil and gas industry who we've seen
really drag their feet and you know put
a lot of eggs in the basket of oh we'll
get technology in the future which will
remove carbon and it'll be all right but
that technology is not getting to scale
at the pace it would need to to keep
removing fossil fuels from the ground at
the pace that we're going so it was very
good to see the Ia come out with that
last year I think a lot of us thought
that's good but it isn't quite far
enough and I think this report we've got
to get the message through that we need
to leave oil and gas and coal in the
ground and that the business model that
the oil and gas companies think is that
it isn't there we've got to make a much
more rapid transition to renewable
technology
but Simon this is a tough ask isn't it
for for oil and gas companies when
they've got projects already running or
they're already in the pipeline I mean
how do you incentivize them to Halt
projects when there's a lot of money at
stake and there's also people's jobs and
people's livelihoods
yes but they've had 30 years of warnings
that this transition is required and is
required fast and what the fossil fuel
industry has done is pumped money into
lobbying into portraying climate science
as as as a as a Miss science and doing
everything they can to delay and delay
and delay the final Reckoning and what
we're seeing with all these heat waves
around the world is that climate impacts
are real and they are deadly serious and
they are destabilar I think to society
we need to get out of them very fast and
there's a bunch of things that can be
done for one the UK government and other
governments in in the global North could
stop giving out new licenses for new
extraction of oil fields such as in the
North Sea and it cop 26 there was a very
positive development in that the UK us
and EU got together and put together an
8.5 billion dollar fund for a GEOS
transition for South Africa to close
their coal mines early and the
co-production and move that Society
towards clean green energy and jobs for
the future and that model is already
being talked about in terms of Indonesia
and
um and India and and those are models
that we can get forward with with but
the UK and the and the US and Norway and
other oil producers need to play their
part as well as the global South getting
out of coal well yes and Helen I mean to
what extent do you think this is down to
government intervention and Regulation
and what to what extent can the market
play a role I mean are oil companies
increasingly seen in future their
profits are going to be made in in
cleaner energy
they sort of say that they are but they
there's a kind of effect that I sort of
call it one last Coal Mine where every
government or company is like look at
our green targets look at what good
we're going to do in the future we'll
just build one more coal mine and then
we'll get on with it and I think what we
need is a much more rapid shift and an
understanding you don't get one more
we've got to make this transition now
and so we've the shift we've seen from
the oil and gas companies is kind of
paying a lip service to it it's a start
recognizing there's a problem but as
Simon says we've seen so much money
going into lobbying on the other side
you see them lobbying governments to
hold up the subsidies they get there's
still fossil subsidies going to fossil
fuel companies we're seeing now they're
making record profits we need to level
the playing field we need to see those
same types of subsidies going to
renewable energies we have the
technology now to solve this we don't
need to wait for carbon capture
Technologies in the future we'll we will
need those for things like cement and
steel but on the Energy System we have
the solutions now we need to stop the
companies and others that are blocking
us from making that transition and very
briefly Simon you touched on this a bit
before but you know the UK may have
issues but they're dwarfed aren't they
by some of the countries you mentioned
Indonesia for example Poland India
countries that need fossil fuels at the
moment to keep the lights on
well UK is is uh not a large in it
globally but then few countries are
large emitters globally because there
are 200 countries and that's an excuse
for not taking the action
it's like that point about you know one
last comment oh we're just not enough uh
of a very important player the UK was
the leader of the Industrial Revolution
and it needs to lead to get beyond that
and go to clean green sources of energy
that are not only better for the planet
they're better for all of us our health
and prosperity going forward I think in
2022
an investment in fossil fuels is an
investment against human progress and we
should remember that as we go forward
okay I'm going to go forward now if
that's okay we're gonna need to crack on
with our next subject
um because India and Pakistan are
gasping under record temperatures many
parts of the south Asia have suffered a
heat wave since March it's the hottest
March in over 120 years so Simon this is
a region that's no stranger to high
temperatures and hot weather is it but
how do you think this is different and
is this about climate change
oh it's certainly about climate change
uh the increase in greenhouse gases in
the atmosphere mean that there's a
greater probability of these heat waves
happening and for them happening for
longer so this is what is uh expected
from the emissions that we've put into
the atmosphere and what's really really
alarming about this these heat waves is
that they that they're getting to the
temperatures that it's very very
difficult to live in and work in and be
productive in and in Gujarat in this
heat wave we've seen birds falling out
of the sky we've also seen a big impact
on wheat production so India is the
second largest producer of wheat in the
world and it was expecting to export a
lot of weed and take advantage of high
prices given the Ukraine war but now
it's just announced that it's going to
stop exporting any Wheat
because of the impact of these
climate-related heat waves on its
agricultural production is a really
deadly serious problem Helen it is it's
got so many implications doesn't it not
just the kind of unbearable nature of
trying to trying to go about your work
in those kind of temperatures but what
can be done about it I mean there are
various modes of adaptation aren't there
that can alleviate the issue for some
people at least
yeah and there's a lot of talk about
adaptation and resilience and I think
that is getting more traction I do and I
know we've sort of divide the topics I
also sort of think we need to not treat
them too much as separate topics because
Asylum said this is about the climate
change that's already you know baked in
due to the historic emissions we've got
to see this as like the start of
something that will continue to get
worse if we don't mitigate so I think we
need to remember that we've got to keep
on mitigating we've got to keep our eye
on sort of every 0.1 degree C of climate
change I think what can can confuse
people is we talk about 1.5 degrees C of
warming and doesn't sound maybe that
much but what we know is that that's the
average warming and that leads to these
extremes that you see in India and we're
seeing this real human cost to people's
lives their livelihoods and we saw that
the the ipcc report which looks at one
of the impacts of 1.5 degrees C of
warming predicted Justice this sort of
impact and so I think it's a wake-up up
call on the mitigation side as well as
adaptation as you say we need to start
thinking about how do you make societies
resilient how do you tackle
infrastructure issues how do you think
about heat at the equator you know
cooling elsewhere
um and so on so I I think it's it's it's
really important to think about all
these aspects of the climate crisis and
when we're focusing Simon on the on the
adaptation side of that what can be done
I mean we talked a little bit earlier
with the guest who talked about you know
refrigeration and air conditioning but
it's much more than that as well isn't
it
it it is and you know we should say that
places uh like India that have had these
heat waves in the in the past and really
suffered now have emergency plans to
deal with heat waves in the very short
term about how to get vulnerable people
to places of safety out of the heat so
there are short-term adaptation plans
which can reduce the mortality you can
reduce the deaths associated with these
extreme heat waves and then over the
longer term then people have yeah to to
adapt in terms of their housing and
heating and cooling particularly
installation of air conditioning
um particularly in places like hospitals
where there are vulnerable people and
then we keep need to keep going back to
the problem of food production and
making major Investments to make our
agriculture as resilient as possible
to keep the food production coming
because we should remember that one
percent increase in food prices
translates into 10 million more people
living in extreme poverty according to
the World Bank wow that's quite as we
see food prices going
apologies
I'm afraid we're going to leave it on
that rather start a stat statistic that
you gave us but we're out of time Simon
and Helen always good to talk to you
thanks very much indeed
well do stay with us coming up next here
on Sky News Trevor Phillips and his
guests debate whether we should end the
war on junk food to help ease the cost
of living crisis that's on Common Ground
coming up next
that's it from me thanks for watching
I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]